guest spots from last week your mom's
house had on staff to live two bears one
cave was Burt and Tom Tom and Bert kill
Tony this week was with Doug Stanhope
salcana was on take her shoes off with
Rick Glassman whiskey Ginger talked with
Riff Raff Brian Simpson was a guest on
Chrissy chaos Anthony Moore was a guest
on Matt and Jane's secret podcast and
Sam Morel was on tigerbelly this past
weekend with the Yvonne had a Malcolm
Gladwell Patrick Pat David was on
flagrant we might be drunk to not have a
guest Eric Griffin was a guest on the
Harland Highway and finance was on this
podcast taste buds battled pencil
vs pen Annie Letterman was on the
Honeydew Liza Schlesinger was on the
blocks podcast and nimish Patel was a
guest on you know what dude